- Michael Avenatti and
his client Stormy Daniels
lost one of their defamation suits
against President Trump and will now
have to pay Trump's attorney's fees.
Let's talk about why.
(twinkly music)
Hey Legal Eagles, let's
think like a lawyer.
Today we're gonna talk
about defamation law
and one of my favorite laws in California,
the Anti-SLAPP statute.
Yes, lawyers actually have favorite laws.
Today we're gonna cover three things.
First, what in the word is an Anti-SLAPP?
Number two, why did
Avenatti and Cliffords,
AKA Stormy Daniels, lose this
particular defamation lawsuit
and number three, how much
will Avenatti and Cliffords
have to pay President Trump?
As always, hit that bell
and leave an objection
if you disagree with me in the comments
and let me know what legal
topic I should cover next.
And as usual, Stella, the legal beagle
is reading all of your comments.
So please keep things Stella-safe.
Alright, so onto the
the Anti-SLAPP statute.
Anti-SLAPP statutes exist to protect
and act in furtherance of
someone's right to petition
or free speech in connection
with a public issue.
The bottom line is that legislatures know
that some people will use litigation
as a sword instead of shield
because they know that litigation
is very, very expensive.
A lawsuit can be used
to censor certain people
if used in the wrong hands.
So for example, if you
didn't like a Yelp review
or someone's opinion, you might sue them
and even if you lost that lawsuit,
you might be able to inflict huge pain
and force them to remove their speech
by forcing them to incur huge legal fees.
So in response, many states passed
what are called Anti-SLAPP statutes.
SLAPP stands for Strategic Lawsuit
Against Public Participation.
So, Anti-SLAPP, you wanna prevent people
from stifling speech by
using strategic lawsuits.
California has one of the strongest.
For complicated reasons I won't go into
the court in this particular case
used the Texas statute
but most of the analysis
remains the same.
So an anti-SLAPP motion
is presented as a special
motion to strike.
When you file an anti-SLAPP
motion it stops the case,
they force the plaintiff to show
that the complaint is
both legally sufficient
and supported by prima facie evidence.
Usually the plaintiff
doesn't have that burden.
They can simply file a lawsuit by showing
that their claim has legal merit.
Not that there is supporting
evidence necessarily,
that's what discovery is for.
By the way links to all of these documents
including Judge Otero's
decision in this case
will be down in the description below.
As well as a lot of the relevant law.
But, now here's where it gets
particularly interesting
from my perspective.
If you file an anti-SLAPP
motion and the court rules
in your favor, it will both
dismiss the plaintiff's case
but it will also award the defendant
attorney's fees and court costs.
The court fees are mandatory
and they are not discretionary.
In the American system usually, regardless
of who wins the case both the plaintiff
and the defendant have
to pay for their own fees
but if you lose an anti-SLAPP motion
which means the court says,
you filed a strategic lawsuit
for the purposes of stifling speech,
then you as the plaintiff have to pay
for the legal fees of the defendant.
So that can be a great
reason why as a defendant
you would want to file
one of these motions
because you can get attorney's
fees from the plaintiff.
So let's dig in to the facts of this case.
Now based on the procedural
posture of this case,
the court is assuming the
plaintiff's facts to be true.
Now that's only for this very
discrete part of the case.
It's testing to see if the facts as given
by the plaintiff state a legal claim.
If the case went forward, then Clifford,
AKA Stormy Daniels would have to prove
her allegations with
facts but at the moment,
the court is taking these
allegations as true.
So according to her complaint,
Miss Clifford alleges
that she began an intimate relationship
with Mr. Trump in 2006.
Five years later she
claims that in May of 2011
she agreed to cooperate
with In Touch Magazine
to talk about her relationship
with Donald Trump.
She apparently agreed
to speak to the magazine
after her ex-boyfriend
approached the magazine
without her approval.
Clifford alleges that a
few weeks after she agreed
to talk to In Touch
Magazine, an unidentified man
approached her and
threatened her in Las Vegas.
Clifford alleges that
the man approached her,
threatened her daughter
and told her to quote,
"Leave Trump alone and forget the story."
Then, after Mr. Trump
was elected President,
Clifford worked with a
sketch artist to provide
a sketch of what she
remembered the undisclosed man
looked like and release
that to the public.
The day after Mr. Trump tweeted out
from his Twitter account
at @realDonaldTrump,
stating quote "A sketch years later
"about a nonexistent man.
"A total con job, playing
the Fake News Media
"for Fools, but they know it."
Exclamation point, Trump posted this Tweet
in response to another
Tweet which compared
the sketch that Miss Clifford released
to a photo of her
ex-boyfriend side by side.
According to Clifford's argument
she claims that Trump meant
to convey that she was a liar,
that she could not be trusted
and she was falsely
complaining about crimes
that never happened.
On the basis of Trump's
Tweet she contended
that it was false, it
constituted defamation
and that it constituted defamation per se,
because it charged her with
committing a serious crime.
Now all of this is
pending in federal court
in the Central District of California
which is located partially in Los Angeles
and this is before Federal
Court Judge James Otero.
Judge Otero is a smart,
very capable judge.
I actually externed on the 9th Circuit
which is the court directly above
the Central District of California.
Literally next door to
Judge Otero's chambers.
So I used to know Judge
Otero's clerks very, very well.
So let's talk about Judge Otero's analysis
in this particular case.
There is a two-part analysis
that the court must go over.
First, is to determine
whether the defamation suit
that Miss Clifford filed is related
to President Trump's free speech
and public participation?.
Here, the court had no problem determining
that it was in fact related
to Trump's free speech.
No surprise there, this is
quintessential free speech,
Twitter is quickly becoming
this generation's public square.
So it's no surprise that the court found
not only free speech but
public participation,
almost anything that
relates to the President
should probably be considered
public participation
for the purposes of an anti-SLAPP suit.
So, that takes us to the second question.
Did Cliffords establish a
prima facie case of defamation
and the court said she did not.
So the court agreed with
President Trump's argument
that the Tweet in question
constituted rhetorical hyperbole
and rhetorical hyperbole,
normally associated with
politics and public discourse
is one of those things
that cannot constitute defamation.
The First Amendment often protects opinion
and rhetorical flourishes
and extravagant exaggeration
used for rhetorical effect.
And the court found that
President Trump's Tweet
was exactly that kind
of rhetorical language.
A published statement that
is pointed or exaggerated
or heavily-laden with emotional rhetoric
or moral outrage cannot
generally constitute
a defamatory statement.
Now the context particularly matters.
In filings before the court
and in a public setting,
Miss Clifford challenged the legitimacy
of President Trump's victory in 2016.
Now you can agree with
those statements or not
but it's pretty clear
that she presented herself
as an adversary to the
President and the court found,
I think correctly, that Trump's Tweet
served as a public
rejoinder, a contradiction
of the claims that Clifford was making
against the President.
To me, and I think a lot
of First Amendment lawyers,
this seems like the right outcome.
You might agree or
disagree with the President
but it's important to have
a marketplace of ideas
and opinions and as
Judge Otero pointed out
in his decision quote,
"If this court were to prevent Mr. Trump
"from engaging in this type
of rhetorical hyperbole
"against a political adversary,
"it would significantly hamper
the office of the President.
"Any strongly-worded
response by a President
"to another politician or public figure,
"could constitute an
action for defamation.
"This would deprive the
country of discourse
"common to the political process."
I think that's right.
The next political opinion to
be silenced could be your own.
The point of the anti-SLAPP
statute is to prevent lawsuits
from silencing the little guy
and while Trump obviously
doesn't fit the definition
of the little guy,
for many people legal
fees can be crushing.
So you may not like
certain political rhetoric,
but on balance, we're
better off with more speech
and not less and we certainly
don't want to bankrupt people
for their political opinions.
So I think that's why this
was a relatively easy decision
for Judge Otero.
This is a pretty clear
case of political rhetoric
and rhetorical hyperbole.
This is one of those rare defamation wins
for President Trump who
often threatens to file
his own defamation suits
but seldom actually does.
And although he usually
rails against defamation
and libel laws in this country,
he was actually able to use
those against the plaintiff
in this particular case.
Now moments before I started filing this
President Trump tweeted out quote,
"Federal judge throws out Stormy Daniels,"
misspelled, "lawsuit versus Trump.
"Trump is entitled to full legal fees."
End quote, "@FoxNews,
great, now I can go after
"Horseface and her third-rate lawyer
"in the great state of Texas.
"She will confirm the letter she signed.
"She knows nothing about me, a total con."
You know, it's statements like
this that make it really hard
to defend political
speech but I still think
the court got it right
in this particular case
but I should point out that
Trump's tweet is not correct.
This ruling has nothing to
do with the sister litigation
over the Michael Cohen
non-disclosure agreement
or the other cases
involving Michael Cohen,
President Trump, Stormy
Daniels and Michael Avenatti.
This was just the discrete
case of defamation
over the 2018 Tweet which
implied that Stormy Daniels
was a liar and a quote, total con job.
It also has nothing to do
with how much Cliffords
does or does not know about the President
or whether she engaged
in a sexual relationship
which I think at this point is
a matter of public knowledge.
So even in victory, the
President gets a lot of
the legal aspects of this wrong.
That's not surprising,
this is complicated stuff.
Okay, so that takes us
to point number three.
How much is this going
to cost Stormy Daniels?
Here, the fees are mandatory
and Trump's lawyers are expensive.
The court will generally
pay for reasonable
attorney's fees but 9 times out of 10
the court will generally look to the fees
that the defendant actually incurred
and will order the plaintiff to pay those.
But again, this ruling only
applies to this specific
defamation case and not
the three to six other
Cohen, Trump, Clifford matters
that are before Judge Otero
and are still pending.
So even through this case was stopped
in the very early early stages
it still required lots
of different attorneys
on both sides, lots of legal briefing
and a ton of argument.
Thus Trump's lawyers are
likely to ask for and get,
somewhere between 50 and
$100,000 from Stephanie Clifford.
So do you agree?
Please leave your objections
in the comments below
and until next time,
I'll see you in court.